I'm not back to where it was before I
had the virus Chris Cuomo says he's
still not back to normal after fighting
off the corona virus I'm not a hundred
percent on Tuesdays Cuomo prime time the
CNN newsman revealed that even though he
tested negative for Kovan 19 in April he
still not fully recovered I'm not back
to where it was before I had the virus
but I can work I could hang out I can
engage with my family talking to fellow
CNN anchor dr. Sanjay Gupta Chris said
he's going to be able to do plasma
donations and he wants to document the
whole thing for a segment on the show
but I'm not a hundred percent and
there's funky stuff in my blood work
that doctors say is what they see in
people who've had kovat so freaks me out
a little bit and well chris is a little
freaked out he said it gives him comfort
knowing he's not the only one so as long
as there other people have the same kind
of funky blood work I'll just keep
taking it one day at a time thank you
for asking as relevant I'm always
telling people about the experience the
49 year old first revealed that he
tested positive for Kovan 19 back in
March I tested positive scare yes as you
might imagine but he continued to film
his show from his basement where he was
self isolating away from his wife and
kids
well the beast comes at night and my
fever has gone up a couple of degrees
and like the last 30 minutes
nights are tough he kept it real like
really real while talking about all the
symptoms he experienced along the way so
yeah I've had I've had a fever you've
had a fever but 102 103 103 plus that
wouldn't quit and it was like somebody
was beating me like a pinata
not long after Chris's wife Christina
and their fourteen-year-old son Mario
also contracted the virus Christina now
has aa kovat she is now positive Chris
Christina and Mario have all since
tested negative but before they were on
the mend Chris's brother governor of New
York Andrew Cuomo said the whole
experience might be a good thing for
their kids you want to talk about
growing up a little bit and seeing
reality a little bit Bella will step up
so it's it's all going to be fine
earlier this month et caught up with
Christina and their 17 year old daughter
Bella
who
talked about stepping up and taking care
of the fam so good news everybody's
healthy how is everybody feeling right
now
we're all feeling pretty good great
Bella
your uncle was talking about and then
your dad was talking about it how you
just kind of stepped up and like you
know and and said somebody's got to run
this household so it's gonna be me I
mean it's not even a decision you know
I'm the oldest to be something and also
for selfish reasons I didn't want to get
sick so the lesson walking here on the
house the better for myself I was so
impressed with her ability to multitask
as soon as I went to isolation
you know she had breakfast outside my
door she was thank you me and she was
being kitchen she had Karolina all set
for her zoom for her class ended with
Mario giving the breakfast taking care
of them you know she she knew the list
of things that had to be done and she
just did
[Music]